thank you welcome to rochford district
council remote meeting of the licensing
and appeals subcommittee and welcome to
anyone watching this via live stream
good afternoon my name is councillor
arthur williams and i am the chairman of
the licensing and appeals subcommittee
the other members are
council german first and could you
introduce yourself please
thank you chairman uh yes councillor
jamet person
and the other one is her councillor
chris haley chris stanley if you
wouldn't mind
introducing yourself i'm councillor
chris stanley thank you
thank you very much before we start can
everybody present make sure that they
have switched off their mobile phones
thank you the purpose of today's hearing
is to consider an application for a
temporary event notice made by john
smith in respect of the premises known
as craft and casks eastwood wrote
rayleigh
please could the applicant
or the applicant's representative
introduce themselves
mr smith
uh you're muted i think mr smith
oh that's better uh yes i'm john smith
i'm the
premises licensed holder at crafty casks
thank you do you have any
representatives with you at all today no
i don't thank you
do you have any witnesses you wish to
call
neither thank you
please could the council's licensing
officer introduce themselves
good afternoon i'm stephen greener i'm
the principal licensing officer for
rocha district council
thank you mr greenman do you have any
witnesses you wish to call
no i don't have any witnesses to call
thank you thank you
please could the responsible authority
introduce themselves
good afternoon my name is andrew padden
i am the team leader from environmental
health
thank you mr adam do you have any
witnesses you wish to call i do not
thank you
have all parties receive the agenda and
reports for today's hearing
thank you
the committee will now
follow the procedure set out in the
procedural note at item three on the
agenda
um
to know the procedure to be following
the german unification of the item four
on the agenda
i'm not sure if i'm which sonia perhaps
you could help me here
so um i i think of all parties have uh
have received the uh the papers chairman
um
we we are following item three of the
agenda which uh which which outlines the
uh the procedure that we will be
following for the hearing um but i think
you you need to uh to start by inviting
the uh the licensing officer uh to
represent uh their report
right thank you very much uh
um
mr greener if you wouldn't mind please
thanks very much and good afternoon
this is a
report introduces an application for a
temporary event notice made under
section 100 of the licensing act of
2003.
during the consultation period an
objection was received by rocha district
council environmental health team
regarding the request of extension of
hours on new year's eve
the application must be determined at
the conclusion of the hearing at least
24 hours before the beginning of the
event in accordance with paragraph 26
of the licensing act 2003 hearings
regulations 2005
and section
105.4 of the licensing act of 2003.
just to introduce the application on the
2nd of december 2021 a temporary event
notice was received via the government
digital service portal from mr john
smith
in relation to a
application to for the crafty casks
appendix a consists of a copy of the
original application form
the notice is for extension of hours for
crafty casks on the 31st of december
between 23 uh sorry 22. so again 2300
hours
until um zero zero 30 hours on the first
of january 2022
the licensable activities are for the
sale of alcohol and the provision of
regulated entertainment i have had um
confirmation from mr smith and i'm sure
he'll present this as his evidence
the regulated entertainment relates to
recorded music at the venue
the maximum number of people attending
the event will be a hundred
the venue does hold a premises license
and conditions can be applied to the
application if considered appropriate as
outlined within paragraph 7.6 of the
section 182 of the licensing act
guidance
the venue is currently licensed and
licensed number
215 and a copy of the license is
attached as appendix b of this report
the application was sent to essex police
and rocha district council
on the 2nd of december 2021 for
consultations with a deadline of the 7th
of december 2021.
the application was reviewed by the the
police and they have not made any
representation against this application
an objection notice has been received by
russia district council's environmental
health team on the grounds that the use
of the premises in accordance with the
temporary events notice would undermine
the public nuisance objective of the
licensing act and a copy of that
objection notice is attached as appendix
c
as stated all parties have been served
with
notices and paperwork and documentation
by paragraph six and seven of the
licensing act hearings regulations 2005.
i'm going to let you jump to the end of
the report if that's okay with everyone
and down to the recommendations
is proposed that the subcommittee
resolves either
to determine whether the extension of
the existing license would undermine the
licensing objective of public nuisance
and server counter notice stating the
reasons for that
second to allow the license plate
activities to go ahead as stated in the
notice without
attaching any conditions
or to allow the licensable activities to
go ahead as stated in the notice with
conditions which are currently attached
to the premises license
and that is the end of the report
thank you very much mr greener um i
think members of the subcommittee may
ask questions now for clarification um i
just have one um
the licensing you said was from 2300
till
0 0 30.
um i i was reading the license and i was
under the impression that they already
had a
license up until 11 30 is that not right
the license that is
attached under appendix b is
specifically for the sale of alcohol
it doesn't mention regulated
entertainment right the venue themselves
benefit from the live music deregulation
which allows any licensed premises to
have regulated entertainment up to 11
o'clock at night or 2300 hours so the
application is from 2300 hours onwards
to allow that the music to continue
they also have tips the box for the
outsell of alcohol so there is a
crossover period that will cover both at
the same time
okay thank you
any other members of the committee have
any questions that they would like
clarification on council mcpherson
thank you chairman um
yes please um steve um if i look at the
application um it is page
first of all actually my first question
will be on page 4.8
so this um application is for
sales on and off
the premises
for this time period is that correct
yes it's to cover both so they can serve
alcohol on-site and they can also
provide the facility for people to take
away alcohol at the end of the night if
they wish
thank you then on page 4.10
uh question five
it isn't answered
uh in relation to have you previously
given a temporary event notice in
relation to any premises or events
failing in the same calendar year um for
which is given the temporary event
notice so
you're correct that hasn't been answered
um but they have answered the question
below um i believe john am i correcting
saying and i'm on the assumption here
there is no um because you have answered
the below sort of points um i will ask
john to verify that for you um to
confirm if you're happy with that
yes this is the only temporary event
notice we put in for two years
thank you um and i think that is all my
questions um just just one just for
clarity as well um steve please um the
checklist
um on 4.11
obviously only the bottom two boxes
are
ticked i presume that that is absolutely
fine normal yes that's quite correct and
with an electronic submission we do the
top ones so we are responsible for
sending out to essex police and also to
the responsible authorities so
if it was done manually um we would
expect those to be ticked separately uh
by the applicant but because it's gone
through the government portal we do that
on their behalf
thank you that explains it thank you
thank you chairman
thank you councillor
standing up i have do you have any
no i'm happy no clarification thank you
very much thank you thank you mr greener
um i believe are we going to the
responsible authority now
i know things have changed is that the
one no
go to
the applicants
yep chairman would you like to ask the
um the the applicants or environmental
health um office if they would like to
ask any questions of the uh of course i
do apologize
mr smith do you have any questions for
mr greener no i have no questions thank
you
mr padden
i don't have any questions thank you
thank you very much
okay so sonia sorry we are now going to
the applicant you're going to the
applicant
right thank you very much um
mr mr smith could you please um
provide your submission thank you
i'm asking for
an extension
of our license until
half past 12 on new year's eve
[Music]
to to serve alcohol and
to play
uh background music which will be
sound limited i don't expect it to be
particularly busy because we're not
having we're not having any
events
on
um i i think it's
much more sensible to allow people to
um
[Music]
see in the new year in the bar rather
than me asking them to leave
just before midnight i think that would
be
unwise
okay
is there anything else
um no
thank you very much right thank you um
i'm now going to ask memphis
i'm sorry
there is one more thing i'd like to add
um
i
had a previous tens
for new year's eve
um
on
2019
um
when we didn't have
uh
a sound limiter on
we we had no
uh trouble with that
that evening
okay thank you
i am now going to ask members of the
committee whether or not they have any
questions for you councillor mcpherson
thank you chairman um
hi john um i'm just wondering if you can
tell me um your premises it's limited to
um 100 people um how will you monitor
this
i don't expect to have anything like 100
people there uh in 2019 we probably had
about 20 there
um
most people are making
uh plans
to go to
uh
to bars
that
are having events
uh i think we're also going to be
affected by
uh covid uh i think we're gonna be
having
my guess is we're gonna be having a
quiet new year
um all around and really it's just
available for
um
our regular
uh patrons just to see in the new year
in 2019
um
i provided free champagne to see in the
new year and i think i got through two
bottles so
it wasn't exactly a huge event yeah
um uh
although i can appreciate that
um
my only concern is should other premises
perhaps close and yours being the only
one open
would you monitor
okay um we're required to have um door
staff in attendance
um in any case and and they will make
sure that the place doesn't get too
crowded
um
i don't believe it's going to get
anywhere near 100. okay so so you'll
have door staff on that yes
great thank you and um also
um my other concern would be as you
close
dispersing your clientele
right um
we have to have door staff on from eight
o'clock
and
uh the company we deal with only
provides them in blocks of a minimum of
five hours so we will have door staff
there and until one 1am
thank you so they will be asking people
to make their way home and keep the
noise down so you're telling me
yes
yes which is what they do now
thank you um i think that is it from me
thank you very much
thank you councilman
thank you mr smith uh councillor stanley
do you have any questions for mr smith
uh thank you very much chairman um
i'm concerned about the
i i do understand that you don't expect
to have a full house of 100 people but
i'm still concerned about the noise
level
not only from your recorded music but
also from your res your
people that are there in in the in the
in the crafty cast
and how would you deal with that noise
level
um
also uh being new year's
eve if you like
um fireworks are generally let off at
all and i would ask that
would you have control over that and to
turn and say no fireworks are permitted
thank you oh
absolutely we have no outside space
um
we're
we're opposite marks and spencers that
the idea of someone letting off
fireworks um inside is
uh just a complete no-no
um
no we we don't have a car park we don't
have any outside space there there is no
nowhere for people to let off fireworks
um
as as far as people making
um noises concerned
uh our friday and saturday evenings are
quite
um full in any case
uh i don't expect it to be any fuller
than that
um i guess there will be
um
you know some some singing at to bring
in the new year but i i think it's going
to be pretty
um loud in rayleigh at midnight in any
case
um i don't think we'll be making any
excessive noise
and as far as the music is concerned um
we probably won't be
we won't be able to hear it inside it it
is very quiet
yeah i'm
really not concerned with rest of brady
i'm just concerned with the uh
with the area that you're dealing with
um
in as much as the noise levels not only
from the music but from
maybe the the uh
people that are there so if you've got
some if you've got some control over
that with your doorman or whatever well
we we have we have the door we have the
door staff and and if any people
are behaving inappropriately they'll be
uh
i don't like to say dealt with but um
that's fine if you if you think that is
the right wording then that's fine oh
absolutely right the the door staff are
there to control the door
and
uh to monitor the behavior of people
um
within within the building
um if anybody's behaving inappropriately
they deal with it uh very well
the other thing was that the rear of the
building is obviously going to be wide
open and my concerns were that
parties as they have
as as the licenses that you are um
people can come in and buy bottles or
whatever the case is to to drink outside
take away
um that there may be
something going on in in the car park
area would you have any control over
that um our rear door is an emergency
exit only
um yeah i'm not thinking about the rear
door i'm just thinking about the car
park area behind you because
right okay this is
yeah i understand now this is a private
car park
um i have
uh two spaces there which will be used
um all the other spaces
uh in the car park are allocated to
the apartments and
other
businesses
there is no public parking
behind the premises at all
okay
well yeah can i just come in there
chairman just to clarify that i wasn't
considering as a car parking area i was
more concerned with people obtaining
drink and taking it around the back of
the premises and having a party on their
own so i want to know if the
licensee will have any control over that
area
i can ask the door staff to keep an eye
on that
if not it's a concern to me
okay i can ask to just
right i i don't
expect
uh
that people will be
taking a drink out i just put it on the
form because it was
part of our
existing license i'm quite happy
to have the takeaways
taken off
um
it's
it's not a great concern for me
that's very kind of you mr smith thank
you very much
thanks councillor sally do you have any
further questions
oh
um
would i be permitted to do takeaways
until 11 00 p.m
this is something that the um committee
will decide and come back to you on this
one
is there anything else comes from
stanley
well that's it thank you very much thank
you very much
i have a couple of questions um off
sales do you do you rely on ourselves do
you do many of our sales in
a normal evening um during the lockdown
that was all that was keeping us going
um
we
yeah we we have a regular trade in
enough sales
um
because we've got
uh
a wide selection of beers that are not
available anywhere else um people come
in with their
um containers and we we sell
containers so that people can take them
home to drink we also have a canning
machine
right
so
people can
select uh what draft beer they want and
we'll count them up for them on the spot
lovely thank you um i presume there will
be no live music
no
thank you
um the two spaces at the back that
councillor stanley referred to i presume
you said they will be used they will be
used for your own car parking yes
all right thank you that's the only
questions i have um
do
i'm not sure if anybody else
has any questions um
steve uh mr greener please
sorry interrupts it was just to provide
a little bit of clarity and a little bit
more information for uh the committee as
well
it says under condition 29 attached to
his license the
patrons permitted to temporarily leave
and then re-enter the premises to smoke
shall not be permitted to take drinks or
glass containers out with them so
they've already got that restriction in
place that the door staff will put those
measures in place
in relation to noise and the noise level
from the recording equipment and
specifically in relation to condition 32
which talks about a tamper-proof noise
limiting device at a level that's agreed
with the environmental health section
that has been set at 70 decibels
to give you an indication of decibel
levels
a human speaking sort of conversation is
averaging and i'm not sure uh mr padden
will
put me correct if i'm wrong
is about 60 decibels as a normal sort of
conversation speaks so it gives you an
indication what sort of level that the
music will be played at
and finally in relation to off sales um
obviously the license at the present
time allows the off sales to take place
up until half past 11 in accordance with
the license so um mr smith could then
obviously still offer the off sales in
accordance with his existing license the
temporary event notice is purely the
extension of the the two requirements
hopefully that helps
thank you very much
um
mr patton do you have any questions for
uh
thank you chairman that the points i was
going to raise have already been
addressed in terms of whether or not
there was going to be live music and if
there wasn't whether or not any
amplified music was played through a
noise limited device uh but that would
appear to be the case at the moment so i
don't have any questions thank you
okay thank you very much uh councillor
mcpherson you're waving at me yeah i'm
so sorry
it's literally based on um
what our licensing officer just
mentioned um
steve um
mr smith has um offered
not to have the off sales for that extra
hour that's um but
it's already approved up to 11 30.
now should we be mindful to approve this
would that sort of be able to be a
condition that we can place on there
thank you
what you can attach is the conditions
that are currently under appendix b of
the license and you can only attach
those conditions you cannot add any
additional conditions on if mr smith has
offered to voluntarily remove the the
sound of alcohol off um the temporary
event notice that obviously will be
between sort of half past 11 and um
past midnight um then he's voluntarily
offered that sort of
facility for as an option for you to
consider
does that help
yes thank you um
that's good thanks
thank you councilman and mr greener um
if there are no other questions we'll go
over to um
the responsible authority to present
their submissions if you have any please
mr padden
thank you um as i've previously
mentioned it would appear that our
concerns have been addressed anyway uh
our concerns revolved around the
possibility of live music
but if that there isn't going to be live
music and it's going to be amplified
music only via a noise limited device uh
we would just ask the conditions in
appendix b be attached to any temporary
event notice that should you be minded
to grant
thank you thank you very much does
anybody have any questions for mr padden
no it appears not very lightly thank you
well thank you everybody thank you for
that um
the committee will now adjourn to
consider the case we will return
approximately i don't know how long
i'm not sure quite how sony will let you
know you're more than welcome to attend
there um
so that um and the decision will also be
sent to you in writing um you do not
have to wait but you're welcome to